hey guys it's Thursday I'm just this is
den and I thought we'd kick today off by
telling you some random facts about
ourselves dude oh yeah sure growing up I
used to keep noise from the basement and
ask my grandmother whenever she'd come
up and give me my bucket of fish heads
but then I get the came eventually I
found a way to pick my locks on my
restraints and found my way downstairs
I found a boy who looked just like me
now he lives upstairs and I look
downstairs my favorite color is purple
sorry if you were holding out for a
remake of Super Mario Sunshine Shigeru
Miyamoto has said he doesn't want to
remake any of the Super Mario games in a
recent interview with IGN Miyamoto said
I don't really want to remake any of
them it's more natural to always create
new mechanics and new games you may
remember that the DS game Super Mario 64
DS was a remake of sorts of the classic
Nintendo 64 title but the upcoming
elephant in the Mushroom Kingdom
Super Mario Odyssey does look like it
could be a pretty innovative entry into
the series Miyamoto previously said
Odyssey will be a little more on the
core side and added some games tended to
be a little bit harder and a little bit
harder to play and then so we tailored
back to make it accessible to all kinds
of gamers and then we go back the other
way now it's time for everyone's
favorite type of news story Update news
Konami has released a massive update for
Nintendo switch exclusive super
Bomberman are the 1.4 patch introduces
team battles four new maps three new
characters and a bunch of cool dude
accessories you'll be able to battle
against other players from around the
world in team battles in which three or
four teams will face off until only one
squad remains if you and your friends
fancy yourselves as per Bomberman
there's also the option to go one team
against for the new maps you'll be
playing on our plain floor desert for
panic factory and classic conveyor belt
most excitingly the three new characters
are based on characters from other
Konami series this pyramid bomber from
Silent Hill who can beat enemies
instantaneously when contact is made
Simon Belmont from Castlevania can draw
bombs in from far away and greediest is
vic viper who has fittingly super fast
movement sony has pulled the game that
promised to give you the fastest
platinum trophy from the PlayStation
Store okay uh five star 1000 top rated
that's not a real game yes the games
developer top rated posted to their
Facebook page which is called best
themes that Sony has temporarily pulled
the game called Clive Star 1000 top
rated requesting the name be changed and
to not mention trophies in the
PlayStation Store trailer the developer
has said they're happy to comply so if
you want to once again be able to buy
this tile sliding puzzle game for 98
then and have the chance to earn a
platinum trophy in under 20 minutes
you'll probably be able to do that once
the game goes live again and is
everything we've got for you today but
do remember if you want to stay up to
date you can catch us on gamespot news
every day of the working week or head to
our games what now app which is free on
iOS and Android and we'll be back
tomorrow with our top 5 stories on the
entire week we'll see you then